with summer blockbuster season in full
swing it's harder than ever to keep up
with all the new footage being released
for upcoming films new trailers are
hitting the web every day for movies you
won't want to miss to help you keep
track of everything Hollywood has in
store for us here's a look at the
recently released trailers that will
absolutely blow your way first kill
Hayden Christensen rushes to rescue his
son in the first trailer for first kill
which unites the former star was active
with Bruce Willis in an intense
action-heavy thriller the movie stars
Christensen as a Wall Street broker who
brings his wife and son to a remote
cabin in the woods for a vacation only
free son to end up kidnapped leading to
him teaming up with Willis's police
chief to rescue the boy look for it July
21st
Briggs be bad things get very weird very
quickly in the trailer for Briggs b-bear
a bizarre dramedy starring Saturday
Night Live's Kyle Mooney really plays
James a man who's been the sole audience
member for the children's TV show Briggs
the bear adventures from the show ends
James sets out to give the story and
ending himself but he must learn to cope
with an outside world he knows nothing
about Claire Danes Mark Hamill and Greg
Kinnear round out the supporting cast
kidnap Halle Berry gets the taken
treatment in kidnap in which he stars as
Carla a woman who goes on a mission to
rescue her son after his kidnapped at an
amusement park the trailer ramps up into
a high stakes highway chase with enough
explosive visuals to leave you ready to
see more on August 4 Detroit this
trailer for Kathryn Bigelow's upcoming
thriller Detroit features attention
soaked look at the Detroit riots in the
summer of 1967 John boyega stars as a
young security guard caught in the
Optoma of the Algiers Motel incident in
which three young black men would kill
fire police the trailer knows exactly
when it should change gears to give you
as hard pomping and it looks like
another powerful drama from the director
of The Hurt
look for it August for American assassin
Teen Wolf that Dylan O'Brien takes a
much more dramatic turn in American
assassin playing a young man who becomes
a CIA trained killer after his
girlfriend is murdered in a terrorist
attack Taylor Kitsch and Michael Keaton
co-star in this action thriller that
looks like it hits all the right notes
the trailer teases the film's action and
the characters motivations without
giving too much away leaving lots for
audiences to enjoy when the movie
arrives in September stronger Jake
Gyllenhaal stars in stronger as Jeff
Bowman a real-life victim of the Boston
Marathon bombing who lost both of his
legs while waiting for his girlfriend at
the finish line
Bowman published a memoir on his journey
to walk again which serves as the basis
for the movie script Gyllenhaal has
repeatedly demonstrated a chameleon-like
ability to dissolve into his roles and
that seems to be the case once again and
stronger the movie is sure to be a
tearjerker but also promises to be an
inspiring trip to the theater look for
it on September 22nd American made Tom
Cruise does Tom Cruise things in the
trailer for his upcoming action film
American made which features the star as
real-life pilot Barry field
a drug smuggler recruited by the CIA to
help fight against the communist threat
in Central America in the 1980s cruised
apparently flew all the planes for real
even at one point stepping away from the
controls to film a stunt despite the
fact that it were totally alone in the
aircraft because use Tom Cruise the
movie also reunited him with edge of
tomorrow director Doug Liman strap in on
September 29 Flatliners if you had
reservations about the upcoming
Flatliners remake this trailer should
set you woody
a new cast is featured this follow-up to
the 80 sci-fi classic with Ellen Page
Diego Luna Nina Dobrev James Norton in
Kiersey Clemons taking over as the
medical students haunted by the dead
after flatlining experimenting with
dying for a few minutes before being
resurrected although we're oversaturated
with remakes and sequels nowadays
Flatliners looks like it has the bit
to honor the original while holding up
on its own take the plunge on September
29 marshal chadwick boseman is a man on
a mission in the first trail of the
Marshall the Black Panther staff plays
Thurgood Marshall the first
african-american Supreme Court justice
seen early in his career as a young
lawyer fighting for justice on behalf of
the black servant accused of attacking
his white employer bozeman seems like a
safe bet to be a big part of award
season conversation over the next
several years and Marshall might just
bring him his first major nomination
we'll see when it premieres on October
13 the foreigner Jackie Chan shows up
his dramatic side in the first trailer
for the foreigner a thriller that finds
the action star playing Kwan a
restaurant owner who's hell-bent on
revenge after his daughter is killed in
an IRA bombing the trailer makes it
clear the foreigner won't skimp on the
action but the serious role has a touch
of chance police story roots and he
proves he can still pull it off in this
clip thank you for your service
following three soldiers who struggle
after returning home from Iraq thank you
for your service delves into the weighty
topic of PTSD and its lasting effects on
veterans the bill marks the directorial
debut of Jason Hall who was nominated
for an Academy Award for writing
American sniper the movie is sure to be
heavy but the viewers looking for timely
thought-provoking drama it's guaranteed
to pay heartbreaking dividends look for
on October 27 Murder on the Orient
Express the first trailer for the
upcoming mystery movie Murder on the
Orient Express that's with the screen
based on the best-selling Agatha
Christie novel the movies all-star cast
includes Willem Dafoe
David Lee Michelle Pfeiffer Penelope
Cruz Judi Dench Kenneth Branagh and
Johnny Depp should be enough to make you
want to head out for a mysterious night
at the movie take the ride on November
10 daddy's home to Will Ferrell and Mark
Wahlberg are back in daddy's home to the
sequel to the hit 2015 comedy only this
the perhaps of extra help from Mel
Gibson and John Lithgow and their dad
the trailer features some standout funny
moments from Farrell and Wahlberg but
the real stars
despite their brief screen time let go
and Gibson check out the absurd deep on
November 10 Coco Pixar is back to tug on
your heartstrings again with Coco a film
that follows Miguel a young boy who
accidentally travels to the land of the
dead the trailer doesn't give away many
details instead opting to use uplifting
music and bright visuals to highlight
the film's humor and heart even if it
doesn't reveal much ko goes trailer
should be more than enough to get Pixar
fans young and old excited to the Rubies
November 22 release Jumanji welcome to
the jungle Jack Black plays a teenage
girl and Jumanji welcome to the jungle
so you know it's going to be interesting
taking place in the same universe is the
first Jumanji film it's these four
teenagers transported into the world of
a magical video game where they find
themselves stuck in the bodies of the
game's characters while the trailer
doesn't explain much of the story beyond
the premise it does tease a ton of
action and one-liners and suggest that
this Jumanji could be a game worth
playing and a movie worth watching
heading to the jungle
on December 20 the greatest showmen it's
easy to buy Hugh Jackman as the inventor
of showbusiness in the first trailer
please upcoming musical the greatest
showmen Jackman steps into the role of
PT Barnum the man who defines show
business as we know it through his
founding of the Barnum & Bailey Circus
the greatest showman trailer uses
Jacqueline's inherent charm to gloss
over some of the senior aspects of my
love story but while it may not be
historically accurate it does promise a
dazzling reminder of the power of the
human spirit what's in Christmas Day
2017 Black Panther what Condor is
officially our new favorite location in
the MCU after the gorgeous black panther
trailer which introduces live-action
audiences to the mysterious country for
the first time chadwick boseman finally
steps into the solo spotlight
supporting cast is stunning and the
costuming and gorgeous visuals
immediately put the movie in an MCU
league of its own
there anything wrong with this trailer
is the movie doesn't come out until
February 2018 thanks for watching click
the blue icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know your love to
[Music]
[Applause]